the Joe Rogan experience podcast with a
panda Paula Casa yeah that boy I sent
him a hoodie that boy so thick he's so
big
he's so what's Lebanese spar with Logan
Paul yeah dude he looks like he's 250
pounds see what him wrestled for reals
Luke and Paul camp wrestle Kinross see
good grass oh well here at state in Ohio
that's amazing see it's moving like you
see that scrambles like this is no joke
I think he's if I don't Dan around I
think he's gonna really fight don't
Dylan dance in the box in that what he
thinks gonna happen did you see when you
see Logan slap that guy unconscious you
know that always yeah if they do well
they slap each other that's fake by the
way Jan's fake you [ __ ] sucks much
bigger than so if you something
expensive he's rich as [ __ ] but if you
will watch him slap that dude see if you
can find that video Jamie of him
slapping this fat guy unconscious you
know that thing where people just let
them slap you you stand it's a
competition you slap me first and I slap
you might be the dumbest thing people
have ever invented ever since the last
dumped thing that was dumber than that
was when they used to tape people's arms
together and have an MMA fight
was that broadcasted yeah yeah yeah it
was X arm dude tape their arms together
and they'd throw head kicks and armbars
and [ __ ] against the table see you the
armbar someone the guys were hanging off
the table trying to pry his arm high
kick high kick high kick
yeah it's so it was so dumb it hurts no
fix this guy's look at this it's big fat
guy and Logan takes his shirt off cuz
that's what you do when you gonna slap a
guy unconscious if I had that buy that
do the same thing yo this guy thinks he
could take it he's got it in his head
that he could take it house by the way
look at this yeah don't do that on kids
do not do that at all like 350 pounds
- that's a big K oh that's a big K
here's what's crazy
you gotta give Logan a little bit of
respect he has all the money in the
world you keep making YouTube videos yet
he signs up for this [ __ ] like wrestling
with most folks in fact now that's
whatever no I'll talk about Paulo costo
like sparring with his ass wrestling
boxing it's it's crazy no you're right
he's crazy look he's having fun right
and part of what he does part of what
his businesses know that guy's got brain
damage guys it's not it's not good I
think it's I think she should be more
way to his blood pressure let's be real
here his cholesterol look at his
headband his head's [ __ ] up from when
he fell forward he fell forward with all
his weight powerful no no you tweet out
goes I wish I never did this here's I
apologize I wish I never [ __ ] did
this dude he wasn't think no he would
have done that sued no trust me here
that guy sign way to do this might hurt
the guy well not only that that that
[ __ ] is obviously something that people
do as a sport that slap [ __ ] is he gonna
let this guy slap him to get him back no
the case it seems like the guys stand in
front of him like the guys gonna slap
him now will you tell the guys emotional
so when you get knocked out you do two
things you get really mad or really
emotion emotion that big yeah that big
guys really emotional well now he has
this the world is to see you get slap
like that to that those comments that
they have you know man those comments
have with a stand in front of juice
Russia though right what is going on
Russians what Weibull Russians have
nothing there so let's slap you to lose
that dumb [ __ ] that lets you hit
them first so dumb have you seen those
Jamie just slap anything less you know
the guy has nothing like there was one
there's one hilarious one where this guy
slaps this kinda face he's just kind of
like fingertips from across the face and
this other guy grizzly clubs him and
just snaps his head sideways and
instantly chaos him he slapped him but
it's if you catch someone palm to jaw
bas Rutten stop yes man I don't get a
tremendous amount of power with a palm
you can do this with your palm never
forget that and it doesn't hurt at all
you can't do that with your knuckles so
with your knuckle hey you go like the
bread hurts but this [ __ ] doesn't wipe
awesome do this
yeah watch this this guy this guy let's
this dude hit him first cuz he ain't got
[ __ ] watch this ready look at that [ __ ]
oh my goodness on the one I saw
there's a bunch I would assume everybody
gets treated a couple that was beautiful
with the technique show me that again
look at the technique the guy turns his
shoulder into this watch this look at
this it's the whiplash that not the whip
and the turn shoulder is there anything
more disrespectful than a slap slaps
people's like when they dias it's like
[ __ ] dude now what happens is they wake
that dude up and he gets to slap him or
him over you're not game set man
[Applause]